for the fans who have been waiting to
hear more Spider-Man news right now Tom
Holland is actively meeting with Marvel
Studios and Sony speaking and going over
everything about Tom Holland Spider-Man
4 and recently in an interview at a
press conference he spoken up and talked
about what he expects from Spider-Man 4
and what he wants going into it we've
also heard from some insiders that he is
going to pop up and fight Tom Hardy's
Venom at some point we do know that Tom
Holland will eventually get the Venom
symbiote but separate from that it looks
like we could be seeing Spider-Man in
venom 3 or perhaps we could see Venom
Tom Hardy's Venom that is to be specific
in an MCU project plus we know that Tom
Holland Spider-Man is going to be the
lead in the MCU moving forward once we
get into Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars so
we'll break down everything you need to
know about Tom Holland Spider-Man the
future of his role in the MCU and what
to expect moving forward and reminder if
you want a chance to win a PS5 and Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items today is the last day for
the giveaway for the month of November
if you want a chance to win all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment down below
we pick a random comment from a random
video at the end of each month so let's
first start off with what Tom Holland
had to say during a recent press
conference with the critic's choice
Association I've gotten a few questions
this morning about this so far talking
about some specific Parts asking what it
means don't worry I'll break down every
and it isn't what some people think but
don't worry I'll explain when asked
about it in the press conference this is
what he said and I quote all I can say
is that we have been actively engaging
in conversations about what it could
potentially look like for a fourth
rendition of my character whether or not
we can find a way to do justice to the
character is another thing I feel very
protective over Spider-Man I feel very
very lucky that we were able to work on
a franchise that got better with each
movie that got more successful with each
movie which I think is really rare and I
want to protect his legacy so I won't
make another one for the sake of making
another one it will have to be worth the
while of the character which I totally
agree with however what he said can be
kind of confusing for some fans which is
why some people have started to freak
out because what he said here kind of
sounds like a Spider-Man 4 is not
confirmed it kind of sounds like maybe
we'll make a Spider-Man 4 if it's good
enough if I like it enough but that's
not the case in fact about a week or two
after Spider-Man no way home came out
Kevin feige president of Marvel Studios
and Spider-Man and Sony executive
producer Amy Pascal both came out
together and confirmed there is going to
be a Spider-Man 4 and that they've
already begun working on what it's going
to be so they confirmed this already
about 2 years ago plus Spider-Man No Way
Homes set up a sequel for Spider-Man
they gave us what the story is going to
be eventually with the Venom symbiote it
seems pretty clear that Tom Hardy's
Venom isn't going to go on to be the
main Venom of the MCU but we do know
that the Venom symbiote is there now so
basically we already know what a future
story for Tom Holland Spider-Man 4 is
going to be plus not to mention we heard
reports a long time ago that Tom Holland
has already signed a contract again with
Marvel Studios and Sony that he would
come back to play Spider-Man for six
more projects this is what was reported
at that time obviously three of the
projects were going to be Spider-Man 4
five and six two of them are going to be
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars and then
there's another which Still Remains a
mystery however we do know it's a teamup
project so it's somebody else's TV show
or it's another film where he'll make a
cameo maybe Deadpool 3 so yes Tom
Holland is speaking here like they're
not really sure about Spider-Man 4 yet
but don't worry Spider-Man 4 is
happening now when is it coming well
unfortunately there have been a lot of
delays but earlier this year a report
from deadline stated that Sony booked a
release date slot on June 27th 2025 for
an Untitled Spider-Man universe movie so
some people were thinking that could be
the Spider-Man 4 release date however
like I said there's been a lot of
changes recently so they probably aren't
sticking this but the main point is that
Sony has plans for Spider-Man 4 so don't
worry about what Tom Holland said
basically what he was saying is that he
wants to do the movie right which I
totally respect and hope that's what
happens but Marvel's confirmed
Spider-Man 4 Sony's confirmed Spider-Man
4 and if you signed the contract s he
has to do it they just want to make sure
they do it right now speaking of his
contract and how he signed on for six
movies three solos three team ups and
one of those team ups is still unknown
like I said in the beginning there have
been reports that Tom Holland Spider-Man
is going to eventually go up against Tom
Hardy's Venom this report came from The
Insider my time to shine hello and she
stated that we are going to see the two
of them go up against each other sooner
than we think and we've speculated a
little bit about this on the channel it
could come in venom 3 Tom Hardy did say
that his goal was to have venom go up
against Spider-Man he said if they're in
the Olympics then Spider-Man is the gold
medal and he would be foolish to not go
for gold so perhaps in venom 3 we could
see Tom Holland Spider-Man make an
appearance and fight Venom after all the
last Spider-Man movie we had was a
Multiverse movie and Tom Hardy's Venom
was in the MCU and then he went back so
now Venom and Eddie Brock are back they
know about the Multiverse now and they
know about Spider-Man so is kind of set
up for Venom 3 to feature Spider-Man so
perhaps that's the one film that is
unconfirmed which Tom Holland signed up
for Spider-Man 4 5 and six Avengers King
Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars and
perhaps Venom 3 fingers crossed at least
because I think everybody wants to see
Venom versus Spider-Man specifically Tom
Hardy and Tom Holland going up against
each other now as far as Tom Holland's
overall future in the MCU is concerned
it sounds like Marvel Studios want
Spider-Man to sort of be the face of of
the MCU which makes sense we don't have
Iron Man anymore Captain America Black
Widow our main faces are gone and we
heard from some insiders that Tom
Holland is going to be the lead in Kang
Dynasty not to be confused with the
leader of the Avengers in Kang Dynasty
but the lead of the movie the star of
the movie and if we think about all the
characters who are left in the MCU this
probably makes the most sense and then
from there we dive into the Multiverse
and Deadpool 3 is supposed to bring a
lot of characters together to make the
overall multiversal Avengers team then
in secret Wars he's going to play a
major part he's not necessarily going to
be the lead of that movie because we're
going to have so many people in that
movie and if all the leaks and rumors
are true then we're going to have Hugh
Jackman Toby Maguire Deadpool Tom
Holland Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans
Scarlett Johansson they'll be returning
the original X-Men are supposed to
return with Professor Xavier Magneto
Cyclops storm Etc it's just going to be
jam-packed with huge Stars so he'll be a
lead but he's going to be one of the
many leads in that movie but moving
forward we do know that we are going to
be getting a Spider-Man 5 and a
Spider-Man 6 and Spider-Man 5 will most
likely focus on Tom Holland Spider-Man
getting the actual Venom symbiote
because from what we know he'll actually
get the Symbiote and use it in Avengers
Secret Wars the reason Marvel Studios is
waiting for this is so they can do it
just like they did it in the comics in
the comics Spider-Man gets the Venom
symbiote for the very first time during
Secret Wars so that is reportedly why
even though the Venom symbiot was set up
in the last Spider-Man movie in the next
Spider-Man movie it's not going to focus
on it but there is a lot of story that
they can focus on for Spider-Man 4 now
nobody knows who Peter Parker is they
still know who Spider-Man is but not
Peter Parker they can go back down the
relationship with MJ and perhaps he
could try to start over again with her
or perhaps somehow Doctor Strange can
erase the spell from her brain but more
specifically he is now on his own he has
no one now he's really kind of the
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man now
that's what he's going to be according
to what we've heard the stories for
Spider-Man and Spider-Man 4 are going to
be a little bit more grounded more
street level and not so Universal which
a lot of fans have expressed excitement
for so a lot is in store for the future
of Tom Holland Spider-Man in the MCU
don't worry a Spider-Man 4 five and six
is coming and Tom Holland will appear in
King Dynasty Secret Wars and another
project maybe Venom 3 let us know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below what do you hope we
see from Tom Holland Spider-Man in the
future please don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the MCU you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter as well and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf woof